all right so this this talk is about uh
recent progress in verifying neural
networks um and i should really
emphasize that the work i'm presenting
here is really the work of two uh with
your former current members of my group
uh eric wong a former student of mine um
and huangjiang a current postdoc of mine
as well as many many collaborators
actually not listening everyone here but
but they've been sort of the leads in
this in my own group and they and myself
have had many collaborators in this
space so i just wanted to highlight some
of the the
point out that this work is almost
entirely you know due to do due to their
efforts
um
all right so i'm going to sort of the
the i guess i'll write as was mentioned
uh earlier on
i would much rather this be to the
extent that's possible an interactive
talk so please interrupt post questions
in the chat i can see the chat down here
um interrupt just unmute and start
talking if you want i would much rather
have some discussion on even you know
despite the fact that it's virtual i
would still much rather have some
discussion on these topics
instead of instead of just you know
getting through all my slides for sure
um and we can certainly go through it
later once faster if need be and and
have time for questions in the middle
and if we go on a great tangent in the
middle that's fantastic
all right so i want to start off well
the the rough element talk is like on
the right screen here yeah so um this
talk has a few different parts um i'm
gonna start by giving kind of an
overview which i assume is probably
background to almost everyone in this uh
in this seminar given this is a seminar
on ai safety um but i want to talk a
little bit about you know the
backgrounds of the the promise and
perils of deep learning what deep
learning can do why it's so great but
also the problems it has
and then i want to talk about verifying
deep learning so how can we create
models where we can actually certify
say that this model will not make a will
not be able to do this classification
model cannot change its label under a
certain amount of perturbation of the
input or things like this how do we
verify sort of things like robustness
properties or or accuracy even for
models like
like deep deep networks
um and this is actually
this is not a new field this has been
there's been very very active research
in this in this field for for many many
um many many years now
but what i actually want to highlight uh
sort of also briefly because you know we
don't i'm still going to cover it at a
high level but i want to highlight some
recent advances that we've made in
verification
and why i've sort of gone i would say
from very much a verification skeptic to
actually kind of believing in it now
um and then finally i want to give some
sort of final thoughts on what i think
the future of verification actually is
okay so let's jump in i'll go through
this briefly because i assume everyone
here has seen the pitch about how great
deep learning is and how you know all
the all
the great things it can do as well as
all the problems it has but it's sort of
a you know it's a required part of these
of these talks right
so i i i like this because i actually
every year or every time i give a
lecture i have to update this slide with
recent examples and it's never hard to
do right so
it seems unavoidable uh and you know
especially for people that are sort of
engaged in the ai community it seems
unavoidable to keep seeing things that
sort of amaze us um so i was personally
the the you know probably the most
notable example i can think of recently
is when i when i heard the news about
alpha fold um
and and the performance improvement they
had had on protein folding prediction um
this amazed me right um i i know how
this how these things work i know how
i've read the papers you know i know how
the architecture works now i'm still
amazed that these architectures can do
as well as as this on on tasks like this
that have sort of been core side through
problems for so long
um as i think was discussed in a
previous week uh language models are
sort of also progressing at kind of an
amazing rate uh so this past i think
a month ago or so google released the
palm model that can do things like
explain new jokes and they really are
new jokes because i i've heard the
researchers at google talking about how
they came up with the joke so they were
inventing these jokes so it's not like
it's mining something joke out there
it's doing things like explaining jokes
about tpu pods and stuff like this it's
the thing that google engineers i guess
joke about maybe um
and then finally i was it's also been
unavoidable to see these pictures from
dolly 2 on twitter these days right so
if you've been on twitter you've
probably seen people posting pictures
like this so these are these are images
generated just from a caption by their
essentially combination of a text
embedding and diffusion model uh it
really is incredible and again i know
how these things work but i am
amazed that they work this well
there is of course sort of a downside to
all this right so so deep learning
models are not perfect and and they have
some really i'm sure that and i'm sure
everyone probably has heard about these
things but they have these these very
well known at this point well publicized
flaws to them too
so we can do things like take an image
of a pig add a little bit of noise to it
and you get a an image that looks for
all intensive purposes identical but
which the system will classify as an
airliner this is uh
alex madre's joke that of course with
machine learning you can make pigs fly
this is not just a virtual problem
either
of course this noise is sort of very
specific and very highly tuned this
classifier but this also works for real
systems too so so um
here's some work we've actually done on
doing a similar thing for physical
patches in optic detection
so we are using similar techniques but
but made to be a bit more robust we
developed this patch that if you hold so
so i mean i should sort of clarify
what's going on here um
we have this uh this this sort of object
detector here so if you look at this
scene here this is yolo v3 detecting
some objects in a scene um all in real
time then we bring in this little this
little uh
picture into the into the scene and what
you see is that very quickly uh all the
objects disappear and it's not like
there's like a fixed number of objects
that can appear here it's just the the
the
and also it's not like it's told to
detect only five or something like that
um the presence of these
of these images here basically confuses
the other detector not just in the
region where the patch is but actually
across the whole image so basically by
holding up a sign kind of off to the
side of a scene you can make an
architecture detector kind of ignore
things in the scene right and you know
if we're starting to
put this in our self-driving cars and
stuff like this i don't really want a
self-driving car that will you know have
all the other cars disappear if someone
you know paints a stop sign on the side
of the road in a certain way that
doesn't seem very doesn't seem very
comforting to me
this is by no means the only sort of
failure mode of deep networks there are
also things like data posting attacks
and stuff like this where if you train a
network such that there's a little bit
of a little trigger in the in the data
set you can actually basically
exacerbate these problems and
essentially have full control over the
classifier things like this
so
without spending too much time on this
because like again i think part of the
people mostly appreciate this point here
um
the bottom line as i see it is that deep
learning systems are vulnerable to
malicious attacks and
i also think this is maybe more
controversial but i also believe it to
be true
is that these do represent a genuine
security threat when it comes to the use
and deployment of these systems um
these are not just sort of novel
curiosities i don't think they are they
are currently right now not the main
attack surface for many for many systems
right there are easier ways to break
systems right now frankly than than
attacking the ai component um
but it will happen
right we are releasing systems right now
that have security flaws in them
um and it will happen right and i think
it's a genuine problem going forward
so
how do we maybe
start to mitigate this problem
where's the problem come from and you
know how how do we mitigate it
and this is where i'm going to introduce
this notion of verifying deep learning
right because deep learning systems i
mean fundamentally they're not you know
they're always someone's like you know
they're always cast as this black box
but but they're
they're not really black boxes right
there's just a bunch of matrix
multiplies and and then uh non-linear
activations applied to uh to to some
some input um
why can't we reason about these things
or how do we formally reason about these
things
and and uh and so the the basic idea
here is i want to ask the question
of what would it take
to make
to to provide some guarantee or to build
a deep learning system
that in some sense was not susceptible
to attacks like these now when i say
attacks like these that's obviously a
very broad category of tax
let's take a very very narrow view here
what would it take to build a system
such that small magnitude perturbations
to every pixel couldn't change the
output of the classifier of a classifier
and how then would we actually guarantee
that this was the case
and
these types of questions can be
formulated as ones of verifying input
output properties of deep neural
networks
right and again to be clear here this is
not a new idea this has been you know
we've been working this for a while but
it goes back well before our work um
it's been well established for some time
now
how you can at least
formulate
uh these sorts of questions
in a in a in a formal manner how you
sort of formalize the question of
robustness say of deep networks and how
you might go about verifying it
so let me just give a quick overview of
what this process is and kind of how it
works so the problem here the problem of
deep networks right is that when you
take an input to a deep to a deep
network everyone can see my mouse right
i'm doing a little pointing on the side
i won't do too much of it but hopefully
you can see my mouse there
um if i were to ask the question how can
i guarantee that a certain point and and
sort of not just that point but sort of
places around that point are classified
well
what is that
sort of asking formally of a of a deep
network but what it's asking is that if
we consider our point this x location
here
and we consider kind of a box some sort
of box around this this would be an l
infinity ball for the case of sort of
small perturbations of images say
if we take that whole box and we feed it
through a deep network
right
the image of this box in say the last
layer the last layer space
is some very complex region right
because these are non-linear networks
they transform things in in weird ways
and so what you get at the end of this
whole this whole sort of pipeline of a
deep network is you get some very sort
of complex region uh non-convex
you know hard to reason about formally
but it's some it's some actually
typically connected region even
and then the way classifiers work is the
classifier will say that you know all
points on this side of a certain line
again after the processing all points on
this side of a line are one class and
all points the other side are different
class
and the problem of verification is to
say i want to verify
that the entire image of this ball
all lies on one side of this line right
that's the that's the formal question
we're being asked to to prove here
so in other words the verification
problem can be formulated is sort of
certifying the fact that say the
probability of the true class which
again is sort of you know this this this
sort of region here could map the
probability of the classes
is greater than the region the the
probability of all the other classes
for all other classes
and then for all kind of uh
perturbations that occur within some
within some region right so where where
this thing here basically this delta
here
uh
there we go this delta here is sort of
the
allowable perturbation and we want to
ask the question
can that perturbation change the class
output
and um
this is made challenging of course i
mentioned this before but this is made
challenging of course by the fact that
this reachable set
is a complex
non-convex set
and very difficult to reason about
efficiently
and we can kind of but but but if our
goal is to reason about it if we're
going to state our goal too reasoned
about this thing then there are kind of
two ways we can go about doing this we
sort of classify the two different
approaches for for verification that are
common
in in the field of of uh of deep
learning
um the first thing we can do is we can
use combinatorial optimization to
exactly optimize over this reachable set
right so we can actually and i'll i'll
this is this is in fact what i'm going
to focus on so i'll talk about even the
formal statement just in a second
um
but it's also important to note that
actually prior to
about a year ago a year or so ago uh i
primarily focused on the second one
which was incomplete verification which
was just sort of verifying an over a
simplified over-relaxation of that image
set which can actually still give you
guarantees but which is not sort of as
which is not solving the complete
verification problem writing it to sort
of tell you maybe there is an
adversarial attack when when there isn't
so
so um
yeah so someone asked in the chat how
should we think meaningfully about
picking the maximum allowable
perturbation
uh this is a great question right
because because
i've sort of
like i i've kind of pulled a little bit
of our bait and switch here um and i'll
get back to the at the end of the
lecture actually because because i think
this is actually really a really
important point um
i started talking about kind of attacks
in the general sense all the things you
could do to mess with with with these
networks and then i said okay now our
goal is to verify that for a
perturbation less than epsilon where we
i tell you what epsilon is can you
validate this property
and and that's and that's that's not
being very that's a bit disingenuous to
be honest um
and and the short answer is there's no
good way to pick this right
you do have to commit to something if
you want to establish kind of what you
mean formally by verification but the
reality is
what you mean by that is going to be
dependent on your problem what is a a
reasonable level of probation does that
even make that does an l
as an lp ball as a perturbation even
make sense to talk about
probably not from a from a true if sort
of we're being honest i mean that sign i
held up right that was actually a
different class of attack that was a
that was a huge perturbation of some
pixels
away from the pickles you care about but
that's not capturable sort of a convex
set and we do have some work in that in
that setting that sort of extends some
of these approaches but
for now let me reason about kind of
well-defined sets and talk about how we
even verify that
and i'll then come back later to talking
about whether this is even a good idea
and i'm probably kind of giving away my
answer a little bit to a certain extent
here
um
but i think actually there's a lot of
value of these approaches
even if
we're in a very limited setting to start
with
so i'll come back to that point later
okay so so um
let me give a little bit of mathematical
detail now about
exactly how we set up this verification
problem for certain classes of networks
and again the details i'll have a few
slides where the the exact math doesn't
doesn't really matter for the for the
rest of the talk but given that this is
sort of you know a seminar in ai safety
i figured i wanted to have a little bit
of formality here and define the kind of
things that we sort of operate on and
and reason about when we talk about
things like verification
so
we can write um
i mean again this is not sort of new to
us this was done well before we started
working on this this space but we can
actually write the task of verifying
robustness like this um of a deep
network uh certain classes at least um
and for now let's assume that we're
using networks that consist basically of
linear functions um so you know z
here in the network structure if i keep
losing my let me see if i can
uh my laser pointer or something
so z here are the activations of the
network and this network structure has a
linear portion where the next layer's
activations are a linear function of the
previous layer
plus a nonlinear activation which i'm
going to assume here is the relu and i
actually will assume that and then the
value is just the max of zero and a
linear function
and i'm going to assume actually we're
gonna we're gonna focus on this class of
network for now
um
uh though
the techniques that we develop here
actually are applicable beyond just real
use but they take a bit more work there
so for simplicity i am going to focus on
on this rally case for now
um
this problem here
is exactly how you formalize the
adversarial attack problem
right the idea is i want to maximize
basically the difference between my um
my uh actually i think i should should
have minimized there
i want to make the the the probability
of the true label as low as possible and
the probability of an alternative label
as high as possible so actually or
either should be reversed the direction
of it or i should have should have
minimized it sorry about that
um
but the constraints of this network are
actually quite simple the constraints
network are just the network structure
itself sorry this problem are this just
the same as the number structure itself
so we're saying you know the previous uh
the activations at the next layer or the
activations actually before the
non-linearity are a linear function of
the previous uh layer activations um the
final activation is the relu of this
sort of pre
pre uh of this linear function here and
then our first layer has to be
within some epsilon or sorry this should
be an instrument delta uh
this should be a an epsilon there um
our our uh our
first layer should be within some
function of the um
of the of the actual input to our
network right and this just
characterizes basically
this whole region on the outside and
we're asking this whole region does not
cross the line okay so basically this is
you know we just want to check the top
class can change and if the solution
that we have here we cannot
minimize this actually um or i think
actually i meant to switch these these
two orders there if we can't maximize
the reverse of this uh of this equation
um to be above zero then the network is
verified
the this portion here is for the linear
portion of the layers this is the
nonlinear activation and this is our
perturbation okay so that's sort of the
the components we have of the problem
now this would be actually a really easy
problem to solve
um a linear program were it not for this
constraint here so every other
constraint here is linear it will and
the objective too and so it would be a
linear program uh if if that's all we
had but unfortunately and this is of
course you know the whole point of deep
networks in some way is they have a
nonlinear component to them right and so
we have this non-linear equality
constraint here that is hard to reason
about
however
using again various standard techniques
which are not too important to graph the
details of but using very standard
techniques we can basically represent
these sorts of equality constraints as a
set of mixed integer constraints
so essentially what's happening here is
that if we have some upper and lower
bounds and they can actually be in the
upper and lower bound they could even be
very very large upper and lower bounds
on the activations
um
and we have these integer variables
which are sort of indicators of whether
or not we're on the positive or negative
side
of the relu operator
we can
embed
this non-linear constraint as an integer
program i mean it's still non-linear of
course right it's now
an integer a set of integer constraints
and we can embed this whole verification
problem
as a mixed integer linear program
okay and this is this is all sort of
using completely standard techniques
here don't worry about the details here
if you stare at it enough you can
probably see that you know if if s if s
i were to be zero
then you have this constraint that z i
is less than zero and it's also greater
than zero so it has to be equal to zero
so that's sort of the left half side if
if uh s i is one then you actually have
it has to be on on the other side of the
equation so this all works out but the
the basic point here is that we can
embed this non-linear optimization
problem this non-convex optimization
problem as a mixed integer linear
program and solve it for example with
off-the-shelf combinatorial solvers
okay and that's that's sort of an
intuition about how we could go about
doing this whole thing right how how we
go about verifying properties of deep
networks world logistics interlinear
programs we have software for that you
know it's yes it's all exponential time
but you know gerobian things like cplex
they've been really really well
optimized for for a very very long time
maybe they will just work
and the unfortunate part of course is
that they don't work
unfortunately
um if we actually try to
i
can't get rid of my uh
there we go um if we try to just sort of
solve one of these mixed interlinear
programs that comes out of a deep neural
network verification problem
we basically can't scale this to
anything but the very smallest size size
of network okay and so that's sort of
the the problem here all right
so that's sort of where we start
and
the real message i want to sort of try
to convey in this talk
is that
i thought up to last year i would say
that we're basically stuck here
um i i i didn't ever and just i mean
that you know uh
we are stuck here right because you can
never scale
actual mixed integer solvers to to to
the size of of of truly large networks i
think we probably
borrowing some major major breakthrough
we probably will not be able to do that
um
but i thought we were basically stuck
forever for for really really small
networks um
you know kind of toy problems entirely
and the point i actually want to convey
more than anything today in this talk is
that we've actually made a lot of
progress here
and in recent years
we've been able to develop solvers and
methods that are
two to three orders of magnitude faster
at verifying
these sorts of problems then
off-the-shelf uh messenger linear
programming solvers
and to be clear this is not i mean when
i say we i mean the community as a whole
um many people here
have worked on those things as well um
so so so i mean us as a community i'm of
course going to focus on some of the
work that we've been doing um but this
is by no means uh a a solo effort so you
know the reluplex solver was one of the
first instances of these that started to
start to improve so significantly upon
off-the-shelf solvers and i think that
this trajectory
i think has actually been very
encouraging and i think we're actually
making extremely good progress here to
the point where these things i believe
can start to be quite useful
so fundamentally why is this possible
right why can we verify networks like
this two to three orders of magnitude
faster than gerobi i mean gerobi's been
optimized for 20 years um
probably longer than i actually don't
know when the first version of grobby
was released maybe someone in the chat
knows um
uh
why can we
do so much better than these these
really really well optimized solvers
um and the answer as always is that
these are not generic mixed interlinear
programs
um they are highly structured
and they're actually structured in a way
that's very different from the typical
structure that solvers exploit so
solvers like ruby they exploit things
like sparsity and stuff like this very
very well they really exploit this kind
of stuff exceedingly well
um but what they're actually quite bad
at is exploiting the structure that we
have in most networks
um so most numbers are not i mean yes
they're sparse but that's not the chief
uh sort of the chief property of them
the chief property of networks honestly
is that we've developed really really
fast ways to compute uh uh neural
networks right the compute sort of the
the output of a neural network
on you know many examples at a time on
large mini batches on gpus to accelerate
them really really quickly right and
this is the main point
the main point is that there's really
two there are two things that make this
possible
the first is that these these programs
are highly structured
and what i mean by that is we can easily
compute bounds on what the uh on sort of
the allowable ranges of the activations
to tighten the problem more
and maybe somewhat surprisingly we can
also easily compute
feasible primal but also dual solutions
to the relaxations of these integer
programs um including sometimes with
additional constraints added in
and this makes it sort of
very amenable to using existing
infrastructure existing libraries to
sort of solve portions quickly
in particular
all the sort of the the things above so
the fast primal feasible
fast primal dual solutions the the upper
and lower balance et cetera these can
all be computed
really quickly using standard forward
and backward passes uh of on these
neural networks
which enables us to leverage the vast
amount of work we've already done in
speeding up execution of neural networks
i.e on gpus over multiple examples at
the same time in parallel etc and using
standard libraries like pytorch
so this is why this problem is really
different from sort of the the generic
uh
mixed integer linear program and it's
why we're able to do so much better than
these these sort of generic
off-the-shelf solvers
okay so before i go into sort of what
our advances are are there any questions
i only have one question so far in the
chat any i'll pause here for a second
and see if there any any any any
questions in general
someone asked can you estimate how much
speed up is from parallelization and how
much is from the algorithm um
it's a good question so so
i can go into detail after i describe
maybe some of the advances here um
the reality is
when
it's not as simple as just parallelizing
like a mix integer linear programming
solver like the the way most mip solvers
are set up is is in a way it's actually
very unamenable to gpu computation
things like this so in order to make
them amenable you have to change the
actual algorithm you're using and our
algorithms actually are quite and
sometimes actually quite a bit worse
than traditional branch and bound and
branching cut methods but they're geared
towards the the benefit you get from gpu
and parallel computation is so great
that it
sort of blows away whatever losses you
have and so actually i would say it's
not just but it's not just
parallelization right it's designing the
algorithm in a way that you can that
lets you leverage
existing compute
in order to solve the problems
right and so it's the algorithms
themselves are quite different
if you had to execute them using
traditional hardware they would be much
slower honestly um if it was all sort of
single thread gpu computation you'd
probably be actually quite a bit slower
maybe not quite because there's even
some benefits there but like it would
not be it would not be a huge a huge
benefit the whole point is the
algorithms are new and different and
designed in a way kind of from the
ground up to leverage existing
neural network infrastructure and that's
what makes them fast but but that's a
really key part to this design because
if you don't do that then then you're i
mean
trying to even compute neural network
sort of forward passes without
leveraging all this infrastructure we
have would be crazy and and similarly we
need to develop really new ways of
solving these commentarial problems that
leverage this this the same
infrastructure
okay so let me talk about what just and
again this is going to be fairly high
level i'm i am happy to sort of maybe
you know if people are curious
afterwards i can delve into a bit more
details but i want to talk about what
these advances are you know at a high
level how does this work how do we
actually solve these problems
efficiently and again this is going to
be very high level here but what i
actually want to point out is that is
that i'm not just completely sort of
hand wavy here um we've actually
validated these things work quite well
so last year and i unfortunately can
have this slide
yeah one one more year i can early
there's a couple more months i can do it
because the the third competition is is
going to be run now in uh in june
so uh you know i had to give this talk
in may otherwise who knows you know
there's always a chance risk of losing
our our poll position here um if i to
talk a a month later or so but as at
least as of right now
we are sort of the champion team when it
comes to verifying neural networks so um
this competition uh was held last year
it's called vnn comp 2021
it was a competition uh organized by my
people many different universities i
think people here were not directly
involved this year but were sort of
involved in setting up these things uh
in the past
and
um our solver which was called alpha
beta crown uh
one
was able i mean the scoring is a bit
complex but what what i will say is it
was
able to verify by far the most
um
networks and examples and networks in by
far the least amount of time and and so
the it was sort of very convincingly um
the best solver in this in this
competition here um and so the the way
this works is that each team actually
submitted different benchmarks there
were um
about 10 benchmarks in the end and then
you were graded on sort of how you did
on all these benchmarks and on almost
all the benchmarks we were either
the top or among the top solvers uh for
this benchmark and and then overall we
we we had the best score kind of kind of
as as a whole i think the total score
was actually the 800 was the best you
could do out of this whole competition
so we were we were very close to sort of
um
the best possible kind of performance i
mean the best possible relative
performance you could have
so how did we do this what were the key
sort of components of this of the solver
that made it work um and i i uh
i'm going to give a very sort of high
level description of that um i almost
feel bad already for uh approving all
the work that pawn did on this solver
which is a massive amount of work uh in
two very simple slides but here's the
basic idea in in two
high-level slides
so the first thing we do is we
use fast approximations
really fast relaxations
of this combinatorial optimization
problem
in a manner that is amenable to um
existing libraries existing gpu
computation
okay and here's here's a basic idea so
we start with our original mixed integer
linear program i probably should have
drawn this the the this is the relu this
is the non-linear uh sort of portion of
our of our networks here um
and when you have a mixing of linear
program these sort of construct this
reluctant is captured exactly so it's
sort of the the program exactly captures
the fact that the output is the relu of
the input but of course this is
non-linear you can't solve it exactly
and so and so this is the problem
but what of course you can do is you can
form the linear programming relaxation
of this integer program by just relaxing
the integer variables to instead of
being between being either zero or one
to being between zero or one
and what this does
is this actually takes this relu
uh this sort of these these these two
lines of the lion and replaces it with
its convex hull over the uh lower and
upper bounds right so that's sort of
geometrically what this relaxation is
doing
and if you could solve this now you
would actually be solving a relaxed
version of the problem
that
that you know would not be exact sound
uh sounds uh or complete
verification anymore but it would give
you a balance right it would give you a
bound and in fact if you're if you're
over relaxation couldn't find a a a
counter example sort of an ever so
example then you would actually know
that you were you were in fact safe
still
so this is sort of the first step and
this actually is what every solver
guerrilla being others will do so the
first thing gerobi does is i mean i
should not quit the first thing it does
is tries to like you know eliminate
constraints and stuff like that but the
next thing it does is it solves the
linear programming relaxation of the
integer problem okay that's the first
thing it does
the issue though is that even this
problem is it it's a linear program now
right it's it's technically a polynomial
time but even this is actually too so to
solve so so how do you solve a linear
program well you use things like barrier
methods or using simplex methods and
those in the way they're implemented
essentially destroy all the structure
all the fast structure we have
in solving the forward and backward
passes of neural networks and so
actually even this relaxation is in some
sense too stringent to really provide a
good
computational unit upon which we want to
base our solvers
so what we actually do which is a very
sort of subtle point and this point i'm
not going to describe because the
details here are quite quite involved
but what we actually do is construct an
even further relaxation of this and it
kind of looks like this so you sort of
take the
upper line actually and you kind of move
it down to the origin and consider that
whole area and that's actually a new
even further relaxed problem
and without going into the details too
much what this actually is is this is
actually a way of finding a
or rather a way of relaxing the dual
problem of this linear programming
relaxation
that's that's kind of what this
realization is based upon
but the key point that's sort of really
important here
is that
this relaxation this one on the right
here for reasons that are that are in
fact complicated
this relaxation can be computed you know
solving the problem with that's this
relaxation can be computed extremely
quickly
and in particular we can approximate or
you know we can solve actually but
approximate the lp relaxation really
solve this dual lp or solve the the the
relax still or really get a feasible
point for the dual problem if people
understand what you know if those words
are tracking that's great if not it's
not a big deal
um we can find actually a dual feasible
decision which is sort of one of this
relative this twice relaxed solution
and we can do that
at the cost of a single backward pass in
the network and that is really the key
um
the key innovation here i mean again
it's actually from several papers
several years ago so this is actually
was one of eric's paper and several
other people derived similar results in
similar ways here um but the point is we
can solve a relaxed version of the
problem
extremely quickly
while leveraging gpu computation
so that's idea number one
idea number two then
is branch inbound
again not a revolution here
but why is this such a good idea here
the reason why branch and bound is so
well suited to this task and in
particular branch and balance like not
things like branch and cut which i know
are sort of the state of the art for
most ip solving but really a kind of
pure branch inbound here is a really
really good idea
and the reason why is that if we look at
this relaxation see so where's where it
comes from right so it comes from the
fact that your your um
value activation here your activation
before the relu uh spans
both of the positive and negative region
you can imagine this same argument like
the same figures i'm drawing here
imagine if i drew those exact same
figures
where either we were entirely always in
the left hand side or always on the
right hand side so imagine like our
upper bound of an activation was always
negative
in that case
this relaxation
both portions actually both the
ultimatization and the dual relaxation
are both tight in other words you know
this this figure here
if you're if your bounds are both on one
side the other side is actually just the
line or the zero the the zero line or
the identity
so in other words if we if we're if if
we're able to um
have
activations that are always negative or
always positive
these approximations are tight for that
for that particular sort of uh
nonlinearity in the network
but this sort of
you know suggests a natural procedure
which is that if you have if you solve
this you know the network and find uh
activations that span the kin span
negative and positive entries you just
split them
you handle one case where it's less than
zero and one case was greater than zero
and in both cases uh these two
portions of the network are both the the
approximation is both tight
and it turns out you can also further
more integrate these constraints that is
in fact less than zero you can add these
constraints to the network and therefore
sort of solve both branches and and kind
of apply normal branch and balance this
process
now
why is it why is this such a good idea
here well the reason it's a good idea
is that what branch inbound is doing in
this case is it's creating many
different instances of basically the
same exact um
forward and backward pass to solve in a
network
and very fortunately
libraries like pytorch are really well
optimized to solve multiple samples in
parallel
that's they all work on mini batches
right this is how they actually get
their efficiency is is by using mini
batches
so the really cool thing here is that
when you set up so you can't just with
normal with sort of normal generic fixed
integer programming solvers this is
specific to being able to solve these
sub problems
via sort of traditional forward and
backward passes but if you set it up in
that manner then you can leverage
essentially mini batch
runs
from a standard library to incredibly
quickly solve these trees
over many many different leaves at once
and so in some sense this this this i
mean of course there there are a lot
more implementation details and again as
i said i sort of feel kind of bad uh to
juan for for simplifying his his work
into two slides here
um yeah so someone asked like aren't
they doing that anyway um so that's a
great it's a great question so the
answer is no they're not
and the reason why so someone asked are
our commercial solvers doing this anyway
and the answer is no they're not and
what they're not doing is the way
commercial solvers work because there's
there are two things i mean first of all
they also use cutting planes a whole lot
that's sort of really what they're build
but the interior lps that they're
solving
they use things like um they find the
exact lp solutions
using methods like simplex and stuff
like that but when you do that you
destroy the structure that lets you
solve these things quickly
in a forward and backward pass in the
network so they do branch inbound to be
clear they split these constraints
absolutely do that but they don't split
them in a way
that each sub problem has the same
structure and can be solved with a
forward and backward pass in the network
that's what they don't do and so that
means that they have to use very
different techniques to actually go
ahead and solve them
and so it's quite i mean i mean
conceptually yes they're doing branch
and bound of course but the innovation
which is a simple idea to be clear but
it's it's incredibly effective in
practice is that you need to set up
branch and bound in a way
such that both sub-problems and of
course all sub-problems you create in
their whole tree um are all solvable in
a single batch call
to a basically a forward and backward
pass in pi torch
and that is definitely not done by
commercial solvers and it makes a huge
huge difference it's a very different
algorithm too because you know we're not
solving even each sub-problem linear
program to optimality we're solving some
relaxed version of it which is which is
an over you know a twice over relaxation
and that's actually very very different
from how
commercial lp solver or commercial ip
solvers are are working here
okay so if any follow-ups on that
hopefully that was those clear to
the chat but uh yeah
all right so what does this look like in
practice well in practice um uh here's
an example i mean i'm not gonna have too
many examples uh but but i want to show
you one instance of this this is a c410
network with about 500 000 parameters um
and what i'm showing here is
um they're the the the the percentage of
examples we have successfully verified
and by verify either mean we find a
counter example so it's an adversarial
example or we prove that there exists no
adversarial example
as a function of running time
right so our approach is here which is
the lighting green and so compared to
other solvers and this is part of the
competition this was the competition
solvers exactly so in this competition
um we were able to much more quickly um
solve
many more
uh samples basically than all the other
solvers until we hit a timeout the
timeout point and just for comparison
because it was asked before if you take
the base relaxation and just basically
run a um an integer programming solver
even with some optimization you
basically get this line here um and and
you know by some comparison if you sort
of look at equivalent points it's about
a thousand times slower to do it this
way
now
there's this there's there's this issue
which i should be very upfront about
which is that for combinational problems
you know a thousand next speed up is is
great but a lot of problems could still
take the lifetime of the universe to
solve that way right so a thousand full
speed up is fantastic uh it's something
to to celebrate but it's not as if you
know we can solve all problems now it's
still sort of a
you know three order of magnitude
improvement on problems that sometimes
could just on exponential time problems
so it's it's it's great it's very useful
i think but we are still very far away
from being able to verify
things like those networks you saw at
the beginning like alpha fold or like or
like uh dolly two and things like this i
mean those would be actually unclear
what it even would mean to verify them
to a certain extent but i think we're i
have to be honest that you know we're
still talking about networks with 500k
parameters maybe up to a million
sometimes and um
and you know
modern networks have many billions of
parameters so so there's still a big gap
here
okay so that's that's that's the high
level idea that's actually as as much as
i'm going to really explain about from a
methodological standpoint uh sort of how
these things work hopefully give you
some intuition about both why you know
it's it's conceptually a very simple
approach actually but the details of
leveraging existing computation to do
these things like branch and bound are
very very important in practice and they
necessitate very different approaches
than traditional uh branch and boundary
branch and cut solvers
um
so someone asked uh one general question
about this type of neural network
verification we only verify a small box
around some data points uh these yeah
yeah so so
maybe i'll yeah someone's just saying
like like what does it really matter to
verify these things
really unclear maybe actually i'll
answer that by going to my next section
uh about about about robustness so um
this talk is about verifying robustness
or has been thus far at least presenting
a notion of verifying robustness for
deep networks
um
but
does robustness matter
for deep networks
and i actually think the answer is no
just just fully honestly i i've sort of
come to his opinion after a long time um
i've worked this a lot this is a this is
a you know
a heavy statement for me to make but but
but i think it's true um because the
reality is robustness to adversarial
attacks is the worst sales pitch in
history
um because i tell you okay look
your methods are vulnerable to attacks i
can make this pig turn into an airplane
but but don't worry there's some good
news because um
if you're willing
to increase your error by like 500
percent
and you know take about about ten
thousand more times to uh you know ten
thousand something you know
times as long uh for runtime
uh to actually you know produce verify
to verify the network then i can
guarantee the no perturbation of this
precise size will change the results
um
who would who would use that
right no one's going to use that
um
it's a very narrow class of perturbation
it only applies you can only do it for
specific images so if i give you an
image i can predict on this image and
say okay this image you know with all
this compute right so if i spend ten
thousand times the the effort of like a
normal uh normal inference or whatever
um
i can tell you this image if i perturb
it it won't change class
but i can't guarantee that it's right i
mean i can just guarantee that it's you
know stable in some sense your
prediction
um
and to create a net that allowed that
even i had to actually pay a huge cost
because the networks that are robust
they work much they don't work nearly as
well as non-robust networks this is sort
of a well-established fact is if you
train networks to be robust you pay a
huge cost in clean performance
so the performance on non-adversarial
examples
so so who on
like
no one will lose this
and so this sort of raises a really kind
of kind of
maybe depressing state of the world
right now but
which i also think is true
um
because i think there is a genuine
real security threat
i i don't think these are just
hypothetical i think they actually
are genuine security flaws that we have
in existing and deployed networks
um
the problem though
is that we're nowhere close to solving
the problem technically
of how to make these things robust while
not losing massive amounts of
performance
let alone like making it practical and
fast enough
and
while i think we're making great
progress and verification you know we're
a thousand times faster than we were a
few years ago
we're progressing just that much and
building bigger and bigger networks
right and these things do scale
ultimately exponentially in the size of
the network in the worst case
and so it's just really like it's it's
really unclear
if these are ever going to be sort of
play a real role in at least large-scale
classification networks
um
so
why don't people care
well i mean i think we sort of we you
know we're we're still deploying systems
why doesn't anyone care about this
um i think there are a few reasons for
this right that people don't care um
the first is that you know we all have
sort of our heads in the sand right
which is true to some extent i actually
think
uh this is this is possibly true
um
and we're sort of just you know it's
inconvenient to to to build robust
models so we just decide not to
there's definitely an element of
but there's also an element where where
um
this doesn't appear to be yet
a practical
issue
right so so
because in a real system you know
you you you probably don't have sort of
full access to a classifier
um you probably probably only queried a
few times like and people are going
ahead and deploying um
classifiers in security
and you know in sort of ins in security
critical settings like face id on that
phone um and you know
i'm fairly certain that if someone gave
me the machine learning model behind
face id i probably actually could break
it um but i can't break it because you
know i can only query it a few times i
only get binary feedback if you could do
it too much it kind of adapts anyway so
it's really unclear what you've been
breaking you can't you know
as my kids have done many times if you
do it too many times holding from your
face you get locked out for five minutes
right so we don't have so all these
things together make it kind of
not impossible but a lot harder to do
maybe you know maybe someone has figured
this out in some sort of but it's sort
of the thing that governments do right
not not just not single people
um
and the reality is i think we're just
not willing to sacrifice performance for
the sake of security against some
unknown unclear threat model
right um
uh okay so someone asked is there some
theoretical work that says the drop in
performance in service of robustness is
not necessary um
so i'm not sure parts like the
positives and negatives of your question
right um but what i will say is there is
work that shows that robustness and
there's there's two bits of work um
there's work that shows that robustness
is at odds with accuracy so that if you
take you know under certain
circumstances a robust model and a very
artificial settings but still under some
artificial settings a robust model
with the same parameter size will have
worse performance than a non-robust
model there's work that says that
there's also work that says though that
you can still over fit the data with a
robust model so robust models also have
kind of universal function approximation
guarantees in other words we can build
robust models that might be able to fit
the data we just don't we just don't
when we're able to
and by the way this this is actually i
mean forget sort of practical uses for
uh for for a second this is still one of
those things about adversarial examples
that kind of kind of breaks my
my my brain a bit because
adversarial robustness you can think as
like a regularizer that encourages
smoothness of your classifier so if
you're robust to these perturbations you
have a smoother
classifier everything we know about
theory says that you know with the same
training error
a robust class a smooth classifier
should have better generalization
performance and we find just the
opposite here so if we fit the data
exactly with a robust classifier it does
not generalize as well
then if we fit the data exactly the
normal classifier so so so in other
words um complexity
like
the natural complexity of sgd
is in some sense
different from the complexity you get of
robust models it's not about lip just
constant smoothness there's something
else going on which is which is really
cool by the way to think about more it's
one of the most actually sort of
forgetting about security side is one of
the more interesting aspects of
adversarial examples but um
there's theory sort of saying both those
things right but we still don't fully
understand it at the same time
um
so i sort of i sort of like
draw a parallel here to software
development
where in theory we know how to build
like secure software but in practice we
sure are really bad at this
um
deployed ai right now is kind of like
this
where we know there are security holes
in things we're deploying
but the difference is
we don't even know theoretically how to
fix it
so even you know even if we wanted to we
couldn't fix it
and yet we're still deploying it so i
think this is going to catch up with us
i think these things will happen
but
until they do
we're probably going to see continued
deployment of these things until we
really start seeing attacks um
in the wild and frequently
but this is kind of pessimistic right
and i i don't think the whole story is
pessimistic here
because
in some sense
i've made this talk about verifying
robustness for deep networks
but what i would actually say is that
this
in some sense sells short
the capabilities that we're actually
developing here
and this is also not a mystery that
people
again including people here um who work
in other aspects of verification
but
the point i would argue for
is that we should be actually thinking
much broader
when it comes to robustness so when it
comes to verification than just
robustness
there are all sorts of properties that
are very
nice to validate
about about networks right correctness
on some
specification set stability coverage if
we can start doing these things even for
small size neural networks this could
actually be
this this can be a very very big deal
and to be good there is a lot of work in
this area but so far it still is
actually using more nutritional solvers
and using less of kind of these these
recent advances
another point i would make is that
why do we even care about deep neural
networks
as a class of model
um
the reality is that what we're actually
talking about here when we talk about
verification we're talking about fixed
depth computational graphs we talk about
neural networks they're just they're
just fixed computational graphs right
that's the static static compute graphs
and what we've actually developed are
ways of exploiting parallelism and
exploiting kind of
gpu compute
to very quickly verify
certain classes
and arbitrary properties really of
certain classes of computation graphs
and now i'm sort of being a bit more
general here
but i really think that the future
of verification
is not about robustness
for all the issues that it has and it's
not really even about neural networks
what this really offers is a
compelling and really new computational
approach
to verifying certain classes
of computation graphs
and there are all sorts of things we can
do with this
and i think the landscape here
really is wide open
so what i'm most excited about
is understanding how we can leverage
these techniques
to basically improve verification
as a whole
of things that we currently want to
verify
and um in machine learning but actually
on honestly also beyond machine learning
so
if you want to know more you know my my
papers describing all these things as
well as my a lot of other information is
on my website
and then lastly i also want to highlight
a a workshop that that
that we are co-organizing this year at
icml so the timing is very good here
because the submission deadline you see
is actually the end of may
so if you are working on these things or
interested in these things or want to
learn more about these things um i
recommend highly recommend either
submitting to or or uh or
attending our workshop
and uh happy to take some more questions
now but but but thanks everyone for
coming again sorry that it couldn't be
in person but it was still great to
great to be here over
over the over zoom you know one more
time
for the sort of the normal pandemic uh
the yes
keeping the pandemic sort of operating
mode going for a little bit longer i
guess but thanks everyone
wonderful thank you zigo um maybe we
have time for just one question and then
i think we have to close out the zoom if
anyone has a quick question
do you have any thoughts about um maybe
developing um other architectures that
you feel might provide um we're like
tweaking architectures to get better
guarantees like for example some of the
work going on with elk and thinking
about maybe maybe that is a potential
way to build like safer models yeah
so
we've done this a lot
and i don't want to say
no uh because of course this can work
and you know
uh people are doing this in fact um
people have come up with you know
activations that are better and and
different structures that are better and
sort of uh
changing the whole notion of like you
know a sequence of linear non-linear
components all kinds of stuff right so
it's changing to be very very different
um
what i will say
is that we've tried to do this a lot
a really really love you know we tried a
lot to make progress here
and
i haven't been able to we
we've really struggled here
to come up with architectures that are
competitive genuinely competitive and uh
and sort of against current benchmarks
yet which are vastly easier to verify um
you can make it a percentage point here
or there when you do this kind of stuff
but
i have we have not been able to come
with a breakthrough here is what i'll
say so i would love to it's a great idea
of course it's like yes of course we
should you know we have complete freedom
as i said there's compute graphs
we can design compute graphs for this
this objective you know we're designed
for verification
and
you know maybe it's just we haven't had
the right idea yet but very possible
right but we haven't been able to do it
and uh you know i i don't really know
the way forward there
all right
well in that case um
great being here virtually as i said a
poor substitute but uh hopefully
someday in the not too far future i can
i can make it out to the
to the west coast again
sounds good thank you so much ego i
really appreciate it